hablamos de las noticias de economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela saludo otra vez
para usted Hola Ángela y vamos a hacer
la actualización y el repaso cada vez
más países prohíben tiktok Pues si lo
hicieron la semana pasada en el bloque
en bloque las 27 naciones de la Unión
Europea también el parlamento danés lo
recomendó a sus legisladores y empleados
el lunes se sumaron Canadá y Estados
Unidos en este último lo consumen dos
tercios de los adolescentes en concreto
dio un plazo este país de 30 días para
que las agencias federales lo borren
occidente teme que china pueda espiarlos
o recopilar datos y poner en peligro su
privacidad Pues esta fue la respuesta de
Beijing
nos oponemos firmemente al enfoque
erróneo estadounidense de estirar
demasiado el concepto de seguridad
nacional abusando del poder nacional y
reprimiendo injustificadamente las
empresas de otros países el gobierno de
Estados Unidos debe respetar
efectivamente los principios de la
economía de Mercado y la competencia
justa dejar de reprimir
injustificadamente a las empresas y
proporcionarles un entorno abierto justo
y no discriminatorio para que inviertan
y operen allí otra noticia de la jornada
Daniela es que Disney va a perder sus
beneficios en Florida en medio de la
disputada con el gobernador y Ángela
pues Todo comenzó con un comunicado
emitido por Disney el 28 de marzo de
2022 relacionado con la polémica ley
denominada no digas gay que fue
impulsada por el gobernador de Florida
ron de santis Quienes son virtual
candidato republicano a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2014 y que prohibió la
instrucción sobre orientación sexual e
identidad de género desde el jardín de
infantes Hasta el tercer grado
escuchemos que decía el comunicado
el proyecto de ley Nunca debió haberse
aprobado y Nunca debió convertirse en
ley Nuestro objetivo como empresa Es que
la ley sea derogada por la legislatura o
anulada en los tribunales y seguimos
comprometidos a apoyar a las
organizaciones nacionales y estatales
que trabajan para lograrlo estamos
dedicados a defender los derechos y la
seguridad de los miembros lgbtiq más de
la familia Disney así como de la misma
comunidad en Florida y en todo el país
elecciones de 2024 hago la corrección
pues después de casi un año de disputa
El mandatario firmó la ley para que el
estado retome el control administrativo
y fiscal del territorio donde se
encuentran los parques temáticos de
Disney World en Orlando y que tienen más
de 75.000 empleados y son visitados por
casi 40 millones de personas al año esto
lo que hace es quitarle el estatus de
autogobierno que ostenta desde hace más
de 60 años a Disney vamos ahora con Los
indicadores
el gobierno Ah bueno primero le quería
contar una noticia de Brasil Ángela y es
que el gobierno
Silva anunció que va a volver a aplicar
los gravámenes a la gasolina y el etanol
que habían sido suspendidos el año
pasado por el entonces presidente
candidato Jair bolsonaro el Ministerio
de Hacienda no especificó las tasas que
van a regir pero sí dice que la meta es
mejorar el recaudo tributario la agencia
especializada router citó dos Fuentes
familiarizadas con el asunto para decir
que el gobierno está discutiendo con la
estatal petrobras la posibilidad de
reducir los precios de los combustibles
esto como una manera de compensar esos
impuestos y ahora si le parece Entonces
sí vamos con Los indicadores por favor
adelante las bolsas asiáticas cerraron
mixtas con china diciendo que la base de
su recuperación económica todavía no es
sólida y que varios factores inesperados
podrían ocurrir en cualquier momento por
ejemplo este país todavía enfrenta
presiones como la contracción de la
demanda y el shock de la oferta dijo el
comité central del partido comunista las
bolsas europeas suben a pesar de que
aparecieron datos que muestran una
inflación más rígida de la que se temía
en febrero por ejemplo el índice de
precios subió 7,2% en 6,1% en España y
para el cierre de noticias bursátiles
del día pues la multinacional suiza
Nestlé anunció el cierre de su línea de
producción en myanmar un país sumido en
la violencia y el caos tras el golpe de
estado del primero de febrero de 2021 la
empresa sin embargo continuará vendiendo
sus productos allí a través de socios
locales por otro lado la comisión
europea redujo los cargos de los que
había acusado a apple en 2021 eso por
violar presuntamente la libre
competencia en el mercado de la música
en línea al abusar de su posición
dominante Este es un caso en el que
Spotify es uno de los demandantes Y es
que Apple Store es la única forma que
tienen hoy los usuarios de iPhone y de
iPad para descargar aplicaciones para
esos aparatos por lo que los
desarrolladores tienen que someterse a
las normas de Apple si quieren acceder a
esos consumidores y precisamente el
bloque comunitario quiere sancionarlo
Aunque ya no tan duramente como preveía
sancionarlo en el 2021 Daniel
agradecimiento para usted y nos vemos
mañana Así es Ángela